going back to what I said earlier on as  marriage being a joke  the people don't care about it  yeah but why would my so before listen  look before we had to fight we had to  fight slay dragons man we had to go you  know like we had to all it took was the  you know she would just drop played  dragons no no no dragons at no but  essentially we had to deal me and you on  on God like right okay for the woman  like we were going the dad would send us  on the quest like this is what  traditionally what men will go and do  just for the smell of a woman and the  virgin woman right now men don't have to  do that men just need a nice car if that  a rental and tender men just need a good  profile picture this got and then  essentially the standard has been  dropped so soon so women control the  standard if they required marriage in  order for us to have sex